the Supreme Court struck down President
Biden's student loan forgiveness program
which was set to wipe out nearly 430
billion dollars in debt the 6-3 decision
signals to millions of borrowers that
they must begin paying back their debt
after a three-year pause as a result of
the pandemic for borrowers around the
country who had been making financial
decisions based on the hope that they
would see this forgiveness it could have
major implications to their pocketbooks
Biden student loan forgiveness plan
which was announced last August sought
to permanently forgive up to twenty
thousand dollars in federal student debt
for millions of Americans
95 percent of the borrowers can benefit
from these actions that's 43 million
people more than 26 million people
applied for the program or were
automatically eligible and of those 26
million more than 16 million were
approved for loan cancellation by the
education department
the plan would cost the federal
government more than 400 billion dollars
the question is really whether the
president has the authority himself to
wipe away potentially hundreds of
billions of dollars in student loan debt
or whether Congress needed to give
explicit authority to the president to
do that Chief Justice John Roberts said
in the opinion that while the education
secretary a member of President Biden's
cabinet has the authority to waive or
modify existing statutory or regulatory
Provisions applicable to financial
assistance programs under the Education
Act he is not allowed to rewrite that
statute from the ground up
writing in dissent for the Court's three
liberals Justice Elena Kagan accused the
majority of exceeding the Court's proper
limited role in our nation's governance
before Biden's forgiveness proposal
borrowers were already receiving debt
relief after president Trump announced a
suspension on payments due to the kova
19 pandemic
nearly three years later those who were
hoping to see at least some of their
loans forgiven will have to restart
their payments not only they're gonna
are they going to have to resume
payments for the first time in three
years but they're also going to have to
potentially pay on a larger balance than
they might have expected before once
resumed the typical student loan payment
will be between 210 and 314 dollars a
month according to a Wells Fargo report
and those payments come in a time when
borrowers are facing higher prices and
inflation people have gotten used to not
having to make these payments and
they've used that money for other things
that money is now going to need to be
put towards something different and so
that could really change the way the
households Dole out their their payments
every month
the share of households with student
loan debt has more than doubled from
1989 to 2019. with 30 percent of black
households 20 percent of white
households and 14 percent of Hispanic
households holding debt in 2019. if
you're paying back student loans through
this they call income-based repayment
my plan is to cut your payments in half
on the 2020 campaign Trail Biden
promised that he would erase or
significantly reduce student loan debt
and he campaigned on his executive
action again before last year's midterm
elections we're following through on a
promise I gave to millions of Americans
student loans just a little more
breathing room so as we enter the 2024
election season it will be notable to
see who voters blame for this outcome do
they blame Republicans and conservative
majority Supreme Court for striking it
down or do they blame President Biden
for maybe getting out ahead of the skis
and putting forward a proposal that
would eventually be struck down in the
court publicly the Biden Administration
projected confidence about the legality
of their student loan forgiveness plan
we are confident in our legal authority
to carry out this program and we won't
let these baseless lawsuits stop us
either but in private they've been
preparing for this very outcome they've
considered a bunch of different
potential policies in response the main
one would allow borrowers with lower
incomes to pay a smaller amount on the
balance of their loans over time and
then eventually have the the rest of
their payment either reduced or forgiven
and separately they've they've discussed
also putting a temporary ban on
penalties for people who aren't able to
pay their loans that would essentially
prevent the federal government from
recommending that people go into
delinquency for not paying their loans
it's essentially like a small reprieve
to help people get back into the swing
of pay
foreign